US national debt is more than 21 trillion dollars.
Yep, that's 12 zeros!
Having trouble visualizing it?
Well, think of it this way.
You could wrap $1 bills around the Earth more than 80,000 times with that amount.
So, how do we get here?
Well, it's simple really.
The government is spending more money than it's taking in.
The government makes money in one key way: taxes.
Your income or payroll taxes are revenue for the government.
It then spends that money on things...
...like social security, healthcare and defense.
The catch is the government doesn't have enough revenue...
...to pay for all of these programs at once,...
...so it borrows money in the same way that you or I might.
Without borrowing money, the government wouldn't be able...
...to invest as much in education, national security and infrastructure.